in this video I want to talk about the
porphyrins and specifically their
structure and relevance to he metabolism
and to the porphyria's okay and this
this video is gonna get a little
detailed more than what will matter as
for our step one goes but I think some
of these details help release a little
fly and understanding when it comes to
heme its structure and its importance
metabolism as it relates to the
porphyria's so let's start with just def
defining porphyrins porphyrins are
cyclic molecules made of for parole
rings parole rings and parole is right
over here
okay that is the structure of parole for
parole rings linked by methane bridges
ok methane bridges ins the methane
bridge and that coordinate with metal
ions specifically as far as what we care
about is iron ions in particular iron
two-plus but there's also iron
three-plus as we'll talk about at some
point later in this series now another
thing to recognize about porphyrins is
that they contain a conjugated PI system
that allows for the absorption of light
in the visible spectrum
a lot a visible portion of the
electromagnetic spectrum which means
they can be colored okay just to kind of
explain that that just briefly that
relates to just organic chemistry if you
want to take it back real quick when you
have double bonds you have they contain
PI bonds single bonds only have Sigma
bonds but long story short we got PI
bond Sigma bond PI bond Sigma bond PI
bond Sigma bond and we had that to
continue to alternate all the way
throughout the molecule and that happens
a molecule is said to be conjugated and
conjugated pi systems can absorb light
and give you all kinds of crazy colors
in the case of porphyrins the color that
we care about is purple and the word
porphyrin or porphyria comes from
porphyria which is Greek meaning purple
okay that's gonna be important as it
relates to the porphyrin the porphyria's
as well see you later
another thing about poor friends is that
they their names and with I N or in
select porphyrins and we'll see more
about that momentarily anyway we have
this sort of
aren't compound right here of porphyrins
called
poor fine okay and it's got this tetra
parole nucleus such a parole meaning for
paroles nucleus sort of just referring
to the idea it's the basic sort of
structure similar to that of the the
steroid nucleus when it came to steroid
molecules right the three six membered
rings and the one five membered ring
here we have a touch of parole nucleus
right so each portion here has a so this
is sort of the parole and there's four
of those parole rings and they are
specifically the a b c and d rings and
they're all connected by these different
methane bridges and each of those parole
rings has a side chain or two side
chains rather so they have those side
chains if we're gonna start specifically
by looking at ring a and calling that so
each each side chain is doing it with s
and a number so we're gonna start it
from s1 to s2 and the numbers will sort
of continue around clockwise s3 s4 s5
all the way to s8 now the side chains
they're the key possible side chains are
AP m and V referring of course to
acetate propionate methyl and vinyl
groups and I've got their structures
shown there in case you're not already
familiar with them but long story short
though the reason why I mention that is
because different combinations or
arrangements of the side chains on the
tetrapyrrole nucleus will give you
different porphyrin types and there are
four key types one two three and four
just to give you a kind of idea what's
going on with type one poor friends
you've got an alternation sort of
alternating a and P starting with s1 you
go AP AP AP AP all the way around if
that's the case then you've got a type
one porphyrin and type three is only
different at what's going on on a d-ring
right you still have that AP AP AP
alteration or alternation but once you
get to the d-ring this is where the a an
opinion switch try suppose AP AP AP PA
right so here we've got that little
switch relative to
to type one and something that's
important realize what's going on is
that type three porphyrins basically
give rise to the poor furnace and heat
protoporphyrin 9 so in in protoporphyrin
9 we specifically have MV m v m p p m
and that came from a type 3 porphyrin
which had a p a p a p p hey right it's
just that the the a's were modified to M
s right in every single case here the a
was modified to an M and these the peas
that were up here were modified two V's
right but these P stay the same they
didn't change but named we'll see anyway
we'll see how that sort of happens in
the actual pathway of heme biosynthesis
cool so that's basically I don't want to
talk about regarding porphyrins let's
scroll down and talk about something
that's related and that is porphyrin
agents so
you